to Nigeria now where supporters of the
coup leaders have taken to the streets
on the country's national day they're
running against International pressure
to reinstate the deposed president nine
days after the military took power
supporters are marking 63 years since
Niger gained independence from France
their opposing moves by the West African
Regional block Echo asked to try to
reinstate president Mohammed bazoom the
group is imposed sanctions and is
considering sending in troops as a last
resort kulila Abdul Rahman tachani says
he won't bow to pressure and is
promising a peaceful transition to
democratic elections
of Duty and fear the people of Niger are
aware of the seriousness of the
situation facing our country we have
always been humble enough to listen to
all the parties concerned and open to
dialogue so that once everyone's
emotions have subsided we can work
together to create the conditions for a
peaceful transition leading in a
relatively short and reasonable time to
general elections but above all to a
better approach in our fight against
terrorism and the other economic and
social ills that are undermining
initials development
he filed this report before word that
some of the country's borders have
reopened
caution intention in the capital near me
after the West African Regional block
ecowas started to implement its
decisions in regarded to the military
Council here in Niger
the borders with Benin are closed scores
of truck drivers are stranded in limbo
as a result of the stiff sanctions
imposed by Nigeria's Regional and
international Partners after the
military coup
the drivers cannot reach the port of
which is vital for the economy of Niger
and its exports
Nigeria also closes borders Nigeria's
military Council keeps stressing that
they are currently waging a battle for
the sake of the country's sovereignty
and this is why they thank the support
they received from Mali Burkina Faso and
guinea who did not agree to implement
the decisions made by the West African
Regional block
meanwhile Western Nations mainly France
started evacuating a citizen and other
Europeans from Niger out of fear of what
could happen to their Nationals in the
country days after the coup that toppled
President Mohammed bazum
foreign
one of the officers behind the coup has
been meeting members of mali's military
government in bamako to increase
security cooperation between the
neighbors former Army Chief of Staff
salifu Modi says he met mali's
transitional president asimi goiter and
several ministers Mali and Burkina Faso
both led by military government to
support niger's coup leaders
defense ministers from ecowas have been
meeting in Nigeria's capital discuss
their next steps Charles Stratford is
following developments from Dhaka in
Senegal
this is the second day of that meeting
we understand as they try to come
together with some sort of plan on how
to deal with this crisis we've already
said that ecos has not put out of the
question potentially as a as a last
resort military intervention but that of
course is trying to be avoided we
understand that once this meeting is
over then proposals from those defense
ministers will be taken to their
respective leaders and governments in in
their countries before an agreed
action is is is is taken we have heard
though already from the Senegalese
government that they say that they would
be willing to put forward troops to
participate in any echoas action inside
Niger
um and of course yeah International
pressure has also been building up on on
Niger we've seen sanctions imposed by
the EU by France
echoas itself has Frozen all of niger's
assets in the Regional Bank and stopped
all transactions in dealing with the
country so despite their being seemingly
these diplomatic efforts we also know
that there has been an echo s delegation
sent to Niger in the last 24 hours or so
so there there are diplomatic efforts
ongoing and all eyes are on Abuja